this video is brought to you by keeps did
you know that two out of every three guys
are going to experience some form of male
pattern ball despite the time they're 35.
yeah i did and now you do too i wish keeps
have been around when i was younger because
there have been advancements in science so
now there are treatments that can combat
the symptoms of hair loss and help you keep
the hair that you have like it's too late
for me i'm already fully bald my hair is not
coming back but you don't have to be like me
you can stop your hair loss early thanks to keeps
keeps offers generic versions of the only two
fda approved drugs for treating hair loss so you
might have tried them before but never at a price
this low that's right if you were thinking oh
this is going to be medicine this is medicine
it's going to be really expensive don't worry it's
not keep start to just 10 a month how does it work
well for one thing no need to visit a doctor just
schedule a quick online consult bit later discreet
package will arrive at your door and you can use
it in the privacy of your own home so if you're
noticing that you're losing your hair it's not
a problem it's gonna solve itself do something
about it for a limited time go to keeps.com
forward slash biographics or click the link in
the description below to receive fifty percent
off your first order and now back to the video
matthias was the first african-american to become
a successful arctic explorer not only that but
according to some accounts he may be
the first person to reach the north pole
even so henson rarely received credit from
his contemporaries for his achievement as
most people preferred to praise robert peary
who's better suited to their ideal image of
an american explorer but inevitably the pendulum
swings the other way it might have taken decades
but the world finally began to recognize that
matthew henson was one of the greatest explorers
in american history he was awarded medals and
honorary doctorates he was put on a stamp and
had parks schools and even a glacier named
after him he was also re-buried at arlington
national cemetery matthew henson is no longer
simply an asterisk in somebody else's career
matthew alexander henson was born shortly
after the end of the american civil war on
august 8 1866 in nanjimo maryland even before
the abolition of slavery his parents had been
free black americans who made a modest living
a sharecroppers despite their freed status
they still had to contend with racist vitriol
and terror attacks from the ku klux klan and
other white supremacists who began lashing
out more frequently after the confederacy
lost the civil war in an attempt to find a safer
environment for their children the henson parents
left nand muay and moved further up north to
a town called georgetown near washington dc
unfortunately both parents died in the years
that followed and while still a young boy matthew
henson found himself an orphan in the care of his
uncle there was one event in henson's childhood
that he later described as having a profound
inspiring effect on him when he was 10 years
old he attended a ceremony to honor abraham
lincoln one of the keynote speakers was frederick
douglass the former slave who became a prominent
author social reformer and statesman in his speech
douglas urged young black people to seek an
education in order to combat racial prejudices
and inequality with these words in his heart when
he was barely 12 years old hanson made his way to
baltimore maryland which was steadily developing
into a thriving poor town he found a job in 1878
as a cabin boy aboard a three-masted merchant
ship called the katie hines under the command of
captain charles henson spent the next six years
of his life on that vessel captain charles took
the uncabin boy under his wing and provided him
with an education besides learning how to read
and write henson also became an adept sailor and
trained in a variety of skills such as navigation
and sailing that would later prove useful in his
career as an explorer by the time he turned 20
matthew henson was a salty sea dog who had
traveled to the far east north africa and
the arctic seas captain charles passed away in
1887 prompting henson to leave the katie hines
and find a new vocation in life the adventure bug
had bitten him but he did not have the means to go
gallivanting to far away lands on his own
and so he went to washington dc and took
a safe but boring job as a clerk for a
furrier's shop but that didn't last long
henson's life changed forever one day in
november 1887 when a navy officer came
looking to sell walrus and seal pelts brought
from greenland he was robert peary an engineer
and explorer who had already made up his mind
to become the first man to reach the north pole
at that point in time period just returned
from his first expedition into the arctic
and had every intention of going back however he
was still an active member of the united states
navy corps of civil engineers so he couldn't just
leave when he felt like it instead he was due to
travel to nicaragua to conduct some surveys on
possible routes for the proposed nicaraguan canal
which as we know today was never built
while in the furious shop peri and henson
got to talking the officer learned
of henson's exploits at sea and was
impressed with his nautical experience especially
given the fact that just a few years prior
the clerk was a poor orphan who couldn't read or
write piri recognized potential when he saw it so
he offered henson a position as his aide for his
upcoming surveying expedition to nicaragua matthew
henson had developed a strong hankering for
adventure so such an opportunity was too good for
him to pass up he accepted the offer and although
neither of them knew it yet began a partnership
that would literally take them to the ends of
the earth the following year matthiensen found
himself in the rainforests of central america
as a personal assistant to peery over the next
two years it was live henson helped the officer
create a map of nicaragua's tropical forests in
search of possible routes for the canal the former
cabin boy performed admirably during the trip and
returned to the united states as one of piri's
good friends he even helped henson find a job
as a messenger for the league island naval yard
in philadelphia but hanson already knew our life
pushing pencils behind the desk was not for him
instead he dreamt about going on adventures again
exploring the untamed lands of the world indeed
it didn't take long for such an occasion to arise
by 1891 henson started building a regular life for
himself he had a steady job was newly married to a
woman named eva flint however peary had received
leave from the navy as well as financial support
from the american geographical society to continue
his exploration of greenland he began assembling
his team and at the top of his list was matthew
henson who eagerly accepted to serve once again
the north greenland expedition party set sail
from new york in june 1891 aboard the ss kite
at that time much of the arctic was a mystery so
their main mission was not to attempt to reach the
north pole but simply to explore greenland and see
if it was an individual land mass or a peninsula
as far as matthiensen was concerned while
he may not have had any formal training or
experience in arctic conditions he learned
by doing he became a jack of all trades for
filling numerous roles during his multiple
trips to the frozen regions of the north
he served as a navigator map maker hunter
fisherman translator soldierer carpenter and
dog handler unlike most explorers neither peery
nor hansen adopted an i know best attitude when it
came to arctic survival they recognized the fact
that the local inuit people had tips and tricks to
help them survive in the seemingly never-ending
frozen wastes of the arctic since after all
they were the ones who'd managed to turn it into
their home they learned how to hunt how to build
igloos and even how to dress in furs even though
other explorers consider the practice undignified
and gentlemanly while piri was willing to
use information from the inuit to survive
his eagerness did not translate to affection or
respect for them but where piri was horrid and
quick to betray people he considered unworthy
henson was compassionate henson knew firsthand
how it felt to be treated like a secondhand
citizen and he had no intention of doing the same
to others he showed a genuine interest in inuit
culture and learned their language which proved
to be an invaluable asset when it came to securing
the help for his expeditions they called him mari
parlock which was roughly translated to matthew
the kind one in turn he wrote in his memoirs that
i've come to love these people i know every
man woman and child in their tribe they are
my friends and regard me as theirs going back to
the actual expedition itself it accomplished its
goal although not without hardships and sacrifices
the mission was marked by tragedy when the team's
mineralogist john verhoff lost his life after
falling into a crash the trip took a few months
longer than expected because piri suffered a leg
injury but in the end the team crossed greenland
and proved that it was in fact one giant island
they made their way back to america in late 1892
this had been matthew henson's first trip to the
arctic and it did well to showcase his skills and
tenacity and to solidify his position as peery's
first man for six more expeditions that they would
undertake together over the coming 17 years the
next voyage occurred the following year this time
there were more men and a bigger ship yet the
mission was a failure due to terrible weather
conditions henson fell ill during this trip after
a long race with death as he put it and required
months of rehabilitation to get his strength back
on his way back in the summer of 1895 henson swore
to never leave his happy home in warmer lands
again but of course we already know how that one
turned out his oath was about as reliable as that
as someone who promises never to drink again after
waking up with a raging hangover one notable
thing did happen during that expedition though
henson took in a local orphan it was on this
trip that i adopted the orphan eskimo boy
could look to his mother having died just previous
to our arrival at the red cliffs after this boy
was washed and scrubbed by me his long hair cut
short and his greasy dirty clothes of skins and
furs burned a new suit made of odds and ends
collected from different wardrobes on the ship
made him a presentable young american i was proud
of him and he of me he learned to speak english
and slept underneath my bunk two more missions to
greenland occurred in 1896 and 1897 which resulted
in the team reaching the island's most northern
point and mapping it completely this was only a
secondary objective though as their main goal was
to retrieve the gargantuan cape york meteorite
that had landed in the frozen wastes of the arctic
the locals weren't too happy with this though
since they used the metal from the meteorites to
make tools the arctic team's continued success
increased the profile of the dynamic duo
of henson and berry in the united states
that made it easier for them to secure funds
in order to go on more missions for the next
trip they intended to set a new farthest north
record this is a term that has lost all value
nowadays but before anybody had reached the north
pole arctic explorers kept setting new records by
traveling a little further each time and the
farthest north referred to the most northerly
latitudes that had been reached by humanity if we
take their word for it then hanson's team set a
new furthest north on two sequential voyages to
the arctic the first one lasted for five years
between 1898 and 1902. this time it was perry's
turn to suffer the wrath of the grim destroyer as
henson liked to call the merciless conditions
caused by mother nature in the arctic wastelands
the commander's feet froze so badly that he lost
nine toes frostbite understandably this injury
kept him on the shelf for a while and henson's
team did not return to the arctic until 1905.
this trip was shorter as they had obtained a
state-of-the-art steamship dubbed ss roosevelt
which was powerful enough to make its way
through the floating ice packs the climax of
this expedition was one of the rare occasions when
henson was not by the commander's side as the team
got separated earlier during a storm this actually
proved to be a problem for peery as he didn't have
anyone with him skilled enough in navigation to
confirm that he had set a new farthest north but
they claimed it anyway and this highlights
their big problem with these expeditions
nowadays robert perry has what we might call
an issue with credibility the guy made a lot of
bold claims and some of them might not have been
true we'll get to the big one about reaching the
north pole in a minute but his claims of setting
new farthest north records have also come under
scrutiny these doubts have also tarnished the
accomplishments of matthew henson by association
but enough of the farthest north malarkey from
now on it's north pole or bust since this was
the true goal that matthew henson and all other
arctic explorers at the time had in mind in 1908
it was finally time for the big one on july the
6th hanson set off on his seventh and final arctic
mission alongside his longtime companion this time
determined to make it all the way to the north
pole they first traveled to greenland where they
picked up dozens of inuit men including cooklatu
who was eager to go exploring alongside his
adoptive father as well as hundreds of dogs and
tons of meat from there they sailed to ellsmere
island in canada where they made camp and
left for the pole in late february 1909.
the simplest tasks became complicated and
exhausting when they had to be done under the
brutal and relentless conditions at the arctic
even just soldering a few tin cans became a job
for a demon in hades according to henson worked
all day soldering the tins of alcohol and a
very trying job it was i tried to work with
mittens on i tried to work with them off as soon
as my bare fingers would touch the cold metal of
the tins they would freeze if i attempted to use
my mittens they would singe and burn and it was
impossible to hold the solder with my bare skin
gloves on when the expedition started the party
consisted of 24 men but only six were present for
the last leg of the journey matthienson robert
perry and four inuit men six almost turned to five
when matthew henson slipped on a block of ice and
fell into the icy cold water in the arctic such
an accident could easily have turned into a
death sentence in fact that is exactly the outcome
that befell one of henson's compatriots professor
ross g marvin who drowned on this expedition
while returning back to camp henson however did
not share his fate as he was saved by uttar one
of the inuit men who managed to grab the explorer
by the name of the neck just like a sled dog and
pull him out of the water they knew it stripped
hints of his wet clothes and beat the water out
of them then following a wardrobe change the
hunt for the north pole resumed as if nothing had
ever happened that was when the commander's nasty
side started to show itself because in that moment
honesty friendship and teamwork didn't matter as
much to him as becoming the first man to reach the
north pole he realized he knew it weren't going to
be a problem and he would have left henson behind
if he had any chance of making it without him
but he didn't and he knew it matthew hansen
was the one who took care of the dogs and
the supplies he was also the one who knew how to
fix the sledges and he was the only one who knew
how to speak with he knew it if anything henson
was the one who didn't need peri on april 6 1909
the team made camp for the last time on their way
to the pole up until this point their camps were
simply named camp number one camp number two
etc but they felt that something special was
needed to mark this momentous occasion therefore
the commander took an american silk flag and
carefully planted it on top of their igloo
christening the location camp morris k jessup
after one of their financiers the six man went to
sleep and woke up the next morning ready to make a
final march to the north pole ostensibly the plan
was for the faster henson to scout ahead and then
allow the navy officer to overtake at the
last minute and claim the glory of being the
first to the north pole however henson's team
overshot their target let's say by mistake but
who knows so when perry finally caught up
to them matthienson greeted him by saying
i think i'm the first man to sit on top of the
world according to henson's journal the mood
became decidedly frosty from that point on even by
arctic standards henson wrote from the time of my
arrival at the roosevelt for nearly three weeks my
days were spent in complete idleness i would catch
a fleeting glimpse of commander peri but not once
in all that time did he speak a word to me then he
spoke to me in the most ordinary matter-of-fact
way and ordered me to get to work not a word
about the north pole or anything connected with
it even though neither one said anything about
it they both knew that the partnership they
had had for over 20 years had disintegrated
and piri immediately went to work to ensure that
he was the one who enjoyed all the fame and glory
and not matthew henson this did not prove
difficult despite his decades of experience
and success racial prejudices against henson
were still pervasive and the world at large
was more than happy to dismiss him as simply a
mere sidekick to the commander even newspapers
of the day decried the fact that perry gave the
honor of reaching the north pole to a black man
instead of one of his white companions
such as the ship's captain robert bartlett
only other explorers who knew matthienson
personally understood how indispensable
he'd truly been to the success of the mission
and the peri didn't take him by choice but
because he could not have done it without
him even after he published his own memoir
in 1912 titled a negro explorer at the north pole
henson still went mostly ignored however karma is
you know what and peary encountered a completely
different and unexpected opposition to his claim
frederick cook a man who accompanied them
on henson's first trip to the arctic as the
team's surgeon he also claimed to have reached the
north pole and he said that he did it first this
triggered an intense debate over who was telling
the truth if indeed any of them were whether by
choice or by force matthew henson mostly stayed
out of the controversy although he disbelieved
cook's story feeling that he was too soft to
succeed in such a grueling mission as far as
henson was concerned he lived a quiet unassuming
life after his arctic days were over he never
tried to go on another mission both because he did
not want to do it without his long-term companion
and because he felt that he'd already accomplished
what he set out to do in the arctic henson found
a job with the u.s customs house in new york
city on recommendation from president teddy
roosevelt himself and he spent almost 30 years
working there he had married again to a woman
named lucy ross in 1907 and had an inuit concubine
named akantinwa while in greenland who gave him
his only biological child a son named anaok this
fact however was not publicized until the 1950s
after henson's death unfortunately in the decades
following his historic trip to the north pole
matthiensen saw his accomplishments swept under
the rug and forgotten while his former partner
was made an admiral and received multiple medals
and honors it wasn't until 1937 that henson was
made an honorary member of the explorers club of
new york and a decade later he received a medal
by the u.s navy for his efforts mathienson's
final tribute in his lifetime came in 1954 when
president dwight eisenhower invited him to the
white house to receive a special commendation
for his work as an explorer matthienson
died a year later on march 9 1955 in
the bronx age 88 in 1988 following a special
exception granted by president ronald reagan
matthew henson and his wife lucy were re-buried
at the arlington national cemetery with full
military honours the image showed henson and the
four men who accompanied him to the frozen edge
of the earth thus some long deserved recognition
was finally granted to five intrepid explorers who
persevered and triumphed in the face of adversity
both from mother nature and their fellow men